[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل 66 سنه وبالتحديد في 13 ديسمبر عام
1956 11 جمادى الاولى عام
1376 هطلت امطار غزيره على نجم الرياض
سدير الوشم الغائط المجمعه الزلفي
الارطاويه وعمو منطقه القصيم واستمر هطول
الامطار لمده 58 يوما دون القطاع وتركز
هطولها على بريده والزلفي فتهدمت 3,000
منزل ببريده واسماؤها سنتردام وغارقه
المنازل التي في المنخفضات بالسلفي
واسمائها سنه الغرقا وجرى لاول مره وبنفس
اللحظه اكبر اوديه ثلج وادي رم وادي حنيفه
كله حزين انه قام يصمد
يشوف القرش كله
مثيره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والحوادث الكونيه قد تفرض نفسها على
التاريخ فتسمى السنه باسمها سنه الجوع
1910 الموافق
1328 سنه هجري
1358 سنه الظلمه اللي هي كسوف الشمس
1371 هجري تذكرت ليله والسنين الخواليه
وايام لا نخشى على اللهو ناهيا وقد يجمع
الله الشتيتين بعد ما يظلان كل الظن بالله
تلاقيه
[موسيقى]